Heute nacht ist der perfekte start einer hammer weltraum mission gelungen bp colombo klingt irgendwie nach
kinderprogramm ist es aber nicht es geht um die erforschung des sonnennächsten planeten und das ist eine riesige herausforderung
denn eigentlich kann man gar nicht zum merkur fliegen die sonne zieht jeden flugkörper stärker an
als der merkur doch mit einem trick soll es gelingen wie das funktioniert jetzt im blick zum science fiction hier gibt's täglich spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
Wir hatten hier ja schon mal sogar berichtet uns entgeht halt nichts jetzt noch mit mehr infos und dem aktuellen geschehen von gestern
merkur ist mit einem durchmesser von knapp 4900 kilometer nur ein bisschen größer als der erde mond und damit der kleinste planet des sonnensystems
dementsprechend gering ist auch seine gravitation
was zu problemen führt dazu gleich er ist der sonnennächste planet und durch die europäische panische mission bepicolombo
wenn man nicht nur erkenntnisse zur entstehung des gesamten sonnensystems bekommen sondern zu den erdähnlichen
terrestrischen planeten überhaupt doch das ganze gestaltet sich gar nicht so einfach denn es gibt noch eine herausforderung
in der merkur umlaufbahn ist die sonneneinstrahlung
achtung zehnmal höher als auf der erde und das müssen instrumente und satelliten auch erst einmal überstehen bis zu
450 grad heiß wird es auf der merkur oberfläche und eine weitere herausforderung stellt die
anreise da denn der merkur ist im gegenteil zum mars oder zur venus nur durch ein langwieriges
ab bremsmanöver erreichbar konkret wird die sonde die
gravitationskraft vom merkur venus und erde nutzen um durch neuen manöver den
absturz ins sonnensystem innere abzubrennen immer wieder muss die sonne an erde venus und schließlich mehrmals am merkur
vorbeifliegen um abgebremst zu werden und auch seine umlaufbahn
einschwenken zu können sieben jahre lang dauert deswegen der anflug die baby colombo besteht aus zwei satelliten zum einen aus dem japanischen
mercure mac notos feric peter mmo und zum zweiten aus dem europäischen märkte planetary orbiter mp
beide werden auf
unterschiedlichen umlaufbahnen unterwegs sein um den merkur zu erforschen die japanische sonde wird sich vor allem seinen magnetfeld worden und auch dessen
wechselwirkung mit dem sonnenwind untersuchen die europäische sonde soll dagegen auf einer niedrigeren umlaufbahn unterwegs sein und die innere
zusammensetzung des planeten erforschen konkret sollen unter anderem die folgenden fragen beantwortet werden ist der kern des merkur fest oder flüssig ist der planet
tektonisch aktiv also gibt es am mehrere kontinentalplatten wie bei uns und
wir sind die krater an den polen beschaffen die permanent im dunkeln liegen dort könnte es nämlich
gefrorenes eis geben und damit selbst dort im umfeld die chance auf leben gestern ist die mission mit einer ariane-5-rakete vom weltraumbahnhof kourou
gestartet und hat ein erstes signal zur erde geschickt alle symbolen bereich erste ergebnisse gibt es aber erst ab
2025 wir sind gespannt wenn ihr dazu und zu allen anderen themen kein video verpassen wollt dann endet meine handynummer auf whatsapp dann werdet ihr
immer
informiert wenn ein video online geht und zwar als erstes dafür einfach hier klicken und ein kleines geschenk habe ich auch noch zur begrüßung und
darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken noch mehr super spannende missionen die
spektakulärste weltraummissionen heißt das video bis dann
bleibt dran